three o'clock let's look kubernetes and
i want to get started fast and I'm gonna
speak fast because I got way too much to
cover but I want to want to get it
covered so that you understand it so I'm
going to give it a little introduction
to kubernetes for developers I am NOT
gonna look at any form of DevOps edci
stuff at all I want to show why
kubernetes is interesting from or rather
how it's interesting for developers and
what you need to know as a developer
because you can't just build an
application and say awesome I have an
app and now it's going to run in
communities we need to know what
kubernetes is and how it works so my
name is Chris Klug I work as a developer
at a company called active solution in
Stockholm we do a bunch of cloud stuff
that's all I'm going to say you don't
need to know any more about me I just
need to say active solution one more
time because they hate for me to go here
already pay my salary while I'm here so
they're very nice to me but this is the
important stuff docker so dr. is kind of
the foundation of why I ended up doing
kubernetes and containerization in
general seems to be really really
popular right now however docker however
awesome it is has this limitation this
is about what you can do with docker you
can contain rates your application you
can say tell docker please can you run
this limit the amount of memory limit
the amount of CPU and if it ever fails
restart it that's it that is not quite
good enough for a production application
we probably want to have more out of it
and we could live with this but there
would be a lot of manual work involved
so we need orchestration so I went
online and I googled orchestrate to get
the definition of what it actually means
and it says the first part a range or
SCORM use this plan or coordinate the
elements of a situation to produce a
desired effect especially something I'm
not even going to try to pronounce I am
for Sweden that is kind of we want to
coordinate things we want to build like
a micro services architecture
potentially we want to orchestrate a
bunch of containers it's orchestration
and then really cool when you google a
word it gives you this little graph of
how much that word has been used
recently
and you look at the end there we're
hyping this now because nobody's really
cared about it until sort of 1900s and
then it got popular mid 1900s and then
at the end we're going to swing up again
because we're doing containerization and
orchestrating things awesome we are
doing the cool new stuff then I clicked
on the graph and it looks like that we
dropped off at the end so I'm too late
into technology again I don't really
care that it's not the most latest and
the greatest but it's cool anyway so
kubernetes is going to be what we're
gonna cover here and I want to start
with an overview because kubernetes you
can jump straight in and you can start
hacking away on it and you can get it to
work probably with some introductions or
demos and things like that but I do
actually want to cover what kubernetes
is doing what are the building blocks
involved in having kubernetes run what
is kubernetes to me that made a lot of
sense it was a lot of reading and
figuring out how things were put
together and how they work because most
people focus on how can i get my app
running on kubernetes not what does
kubernetes actually do but I'm the kind
of person I want to know what it does so
that when it fails I know how to fix it
or abandon it and go somewhere else so
first of all we have machines you know
let's start very very low level we're
gonna have hardware the difference
between running your average application
and real in kubernetes is that all of
your machines are split into two groups
you generally splitting them something
like this so there's going to be a few
work master nodes so master nodes is
your what's called the control plane
that's where you tell it what to do in
it orchestrates and get things running
and it basically that's where you're
kind of your logic lives and how you
control your cluster and then you have
worker nodes I they used to be called
minions which is just so much better of
a name I'm gonna pull up a new minion
yes worker nodes or minions are
basically your machines that will run
your workloads so you tell the master
plane or the master nodes or the control
plane that I want to run these nodes and
then they fear these containers and then
the they figure out how to get those
containers spread across the different
worker nodes in your cluster so you get
an even use of resources they figure out
if a node goes down and gets reschedule
and so on so you've got those two
different kinds of nodes unless you're
running in a cloud so if you're running
on e KS o g KS or a KS which is Amazon
and Google and and after if you get as
kubernetes service from any of those the
control plane is not going to be one of
your machines so you don't have to put
up your own machines for the master
nodes you've put up your your worker
nodes but the master nodes is handed
handled by the provider for you so they
will give you those that control level
but then you pay for your your actual
nodes so the control plane the control
plane is is actually fairly simple but
it took a little while at least for me I
might be really dumb but it took me a
while to figure out what was actually
happening so first of all desired state
with kubernetes and when you talk to the
kubernetes cluster you actually don't
tell it that I want to run hey start up
a container for me please start this
container for me please do what you do
is you say I want this to be my desired
state I would like there to be three
containers running at any point of time
and then that's your desired state and
then it's up to kubernetes to figure out
that your three container instances are
always running and they're nicely spread
across the different worker nodes so
it's all about desired state not about
telling it do this do that so the very
very very high-level overview of this is
this so the user comes in it has a
desired state configuration that desired
state configuration which is generally
kept in a llamó file it's pushed to a
REST API so it's sent up to the REST API
if the connection is secure and all of
that but basically you send it up to the
REST API the REST API which is part of
your control plane takes that desire
state configuration and puts it into a
database
it's called etcd it's a key/value pair
data store that's it
well and actually before I said that's
kind of what your big part of your
control plan does when you do that it
kind of ends there your interaction with
kubernetes ends at that point once that
is in there there is something in the
Incubus called the consume controller
manager that continuously asks the API
or there any changes or there any has
anything happened and it will find out
it will get that new desired state and
it's gonna go yes somebody told me that
this is a new piece of states that we
should handle and the cube controller
manager or actually the scheduler
controller they're different there are
quite a few different controllers
running inside of it but you can see as
a controller as a piece of software that
makes it just runs continuously in the
cluster and the control plane to verify
that changes end up doing something so
the scheduler controller will have a
look at your despite desired state
configuration to figure out that hey you
told me to run three instances of this
container it then asked the API for the
nodes in the cluster basically how many
work your nodes do I have and what are
their current workloads how much stuff
is running on them right now it figures
out what nodes are relevant to run the
new workloads so it basically assigns
different work node names to your desire
state configuration and restore that
state configuration in storage again
that's it if you can stop here if you
only have master nodes that's also going
to happen you're gonna have stuff going
in and out of a database that's it it
does not go around telling anything
anybody to do anything at all it's just
add stuff to database that's it then we
have the worker nodes that are
responsible for actually running our
toad or our workloads and if we look at
the worker knows they are just separate
machines but they're in the same network
as your control plane and they will be
running some form of container runtime
most people look at this and go oh
kubernetes runs docker nope
Cabrera's can run docker and by default
runs docker but it doesn't actually
necessarily run
you can run a few different container
runtimes and they're also making that a
standard so now you can go and say I
have a container runtime that adheres to
this API and then you can replace it so
a couple of options would be to run
instead of docker you can switch it out
for CR CR IO or container D container D
also happens to be the runtime for
containers that runs inside of docker
but it's a smaller version of docker
without a bunch of stuff that you don't
need if you're not using docker as
docker but you're using docker inside of
a camera's cluster but basically you
have a container runtime that will run
your containers it will do the work for
you then your working out has something
called the cubelets accumulate it's a
piece of code that runs on that worker
node that knows how to talk to the
control plane so the cubelet
continuously just as the worker the
controllers on the worker know
masternodes was asking the api for
changes the cubelet asks the control
planer the rest api continuously is
there anything that should be scheduled
on me is there anything that i should be
running that I'm not running is there
anything I should be running now I'm not
running over and over and over again
until the control plane or the API goes
back and says yes you should be running
this node as well we're sorry you should
run in this container as well the cube
let then talks to the container runtime
and tells to contain a runtime that hey
can you please schedule these containers
and run them for me so kubernetes
doesn't do anything but tell doctor what
to do or they contain a runtime so it's
basically just a little managing thing
that sits there and goes you want me to
run at least so many of these I'll
figure out where to run them and then
I'll make sure that they get scheduled
on that but it's still running in this
case docker for example so I'm going to
show you that when I run kubernetes on
my machine when I spin up a docker
container inside my kubernetes cluster I
can see that in the regular docker
commands on my machine so I can go and
say dr. PS and actually see the running
containers I can interact with them and
I can make changes to them kubernetes is
just there on the side helping us out to
make sure that they run as they should
and finally there's something called the
cube
see the cube proxy is a way to manage
communication inside the cluster so
whenever you want to talk inside of the
cluster between different containers you
end up with the situation that your
calls gets proxied through a cube proxy
to make sure that because you can't
really take a dependency and say I want
to talk to point to container X because
container X might or might not be there
between two different calls so to make
that work it always proxies through a
proxy server that can handle the changes
in the containers coming and going
continuously that's it very high-level
introduction 11 minutes and I'm done
with my talk I thought I'd actually give
you some practical stuff as well so
we're going to look at the building
blocks that we'll be building
because the thing is there is little
things there like little blocks that we
pull out and we go I need one of those I
need one of those I need one of those we
put them together like Legos and all the
sudden we have a system kind of nice and
it's fast on top of that which is cool
so the first thing I want to cover is
the pod I have been talking about
running containers so far in my talk you
don't actually run containers in
kubernetes you do under the hood so low
level wise yes we are running containers
on worker nodes in the cluster but you
cannot schedule a container or tell
kubernetes to run a container you always
tell it to run a pod so a pod is the
smallest unit that we can tell
kubernetes to work with a pod contains
one or more containers that's about it
it is perfectly fine to have a pod with
just one container in it but the pod is
the smallest thing and the reason for a
pod is that we often have this idea of
containers working together so if you
put a container inside of the same pod
or multiple containers in the same pod
they will all have the same IP address
so they will share the same address
namespace but so they cannot expose the
same port but they can you can have as
many containers as you want inside the
pod and as long as none of them expose
the same port as another container
you're good to go that's fine they also
have the ability to communicate between
each other
with inter-process communication so they
can't communicate in a different way
than over the network like you normally
would because they're kind of process
together and they can share storage so
if you set up storage inside your pod
you can have all the containers in your
pod or some of them read this read and
write to the same storage which can be
really really useful and then you
basically schedule pods in your
application or in your communities
cluster so it works one thing to note
sorry before I got in the slide it might
seem obvious that certain thing oh I'm
gonna put these containers together
remember when you combine containers
into a pod remember that they scale
together it's not a matter of how do I
want to basically put this into
production so more of a how do I want to
scale this because it does scale
together so it might seem obvious that
hey I'm gonna take my WordPress website
and the database and I'm gonna put those
two containers in the same pod because
they belong together so communication is
going to be really quick between the
database and the WordPress site right
until you start scaling up and you
realize that you get one database per
word precise site will work for instance
of your so load balancing that would be
a bit of a fail because you'd basically
add things to one and it wouldn't be
available in the other so every other
time you refresh the webpage you would
get some data and then in some case you
give some other data it would kind of be
a failure of websites to be perfectly
honest but let's get a bit more
practical so how do we work with this
now we know we have a pod and we can
schedule container so we can run
containers based on pods well first of
all how do we run it in our local
machines well if we want to run it on
our local machines you install docker
for desktop which is the easiest way to
get up it works on Windows and Mac
without a problem on Linux you can just
run the docker natively but on Windows
and Mac you run this and then you go
into the settings and you take that
little thing that says enable kubernetes
and all the sudden your machine is now a
one node kubernetes cluster with the
master node and the
worker node being the same node which
for production use is a big big big
no-no but for running locally on your
machine trying stuff out it works fine
with that you also get this cool little
command called cube CTL cube control or
my personal favorite cubby couple so
Chemical is this tool that helps us talk
to the REST API we could build their own
recipe API client but we'd have to
implement security so we need to
implement authentication but other than
that telling kubernetes to do something
is just a matter of posting or getting
things in and out of a REST API that's
it but cubby cuttle will do that for you
in a very very nice way and it's a very
simple command cube CTL space whatever
you want to do I want to get something I
want to delete something I want to
create something and then the resource
type that you want to do so pod for
example and then if you go with just
that cube CT I'll get pods by the way
the S at the end isn't mandatory
actually you can go cube CTL don't get P
oh that's enough for it to figure out
that you want pods and it will give you
all the pods back that will give you a
list of all running pods in your cluster
not quite but ish and this will give you
a specific body this will give you the
information about the pod called my pod
so now you know how to use chemical
that's all you need if you want to
create something you can call the create
command or most people just go with
apply apply works both for creation and
updates so it's like a create update
command and you call cube CTL apply dash
F telling it that I have a file and here
is my Yama file that contains my
configuration and you just call that and
all the sudden there is some stuff
running in your cluster piece of cake
it also has one other cool feature and
that is port forwarding the problem are
not the problem but one of the things
with the way that kubernetes and also
docker works to be honest is that
everything you put in to kubernetes
works in its own networks namespace
network area right so it's a separate
network from your local machine even
though I'm running docker for win the
docker for desktop on my machine docker
actually runs currently in this version
inside of an Linux VM that runs in
hyper-v so it runs in a completely
separate thing so I can't just go and
say hey go to my browser and go
localhost port 80 and it's gonna hit my
container that's just the way it works
so what cubby cuttle offers is port
forwarding so what we can say here is
hey cube CTL can you please port forward
port 8080 on my local machine to port 80
inside of the pod
called my pod and then while that is
running it looks this basically looks
the thread or not while that is running
you can then go to your browser and just
go it should be colon slash slash look
HTTP localhost port 8080 and you go
straight into it and it's so cool it's
actually transparent enough that I've
done this talk once before a couple of
times before but I did it in Stockholm
and I did the whole talk there's one
little demo that failed I couldn't
explain why I couldn't see a container
running in my cluster in my local docker
stuff so I went docker PS and I couldn't
see my container and I was like weird
I don't know quite why probably some
weird configuration thing and then I
realized the day after that I had run my
entire presentation in a cluster in
Asscher instead of my local machine
because I'd forgotten to switch clusters
but with port forwarding it doesn't
matter if I'm port forwarding locally on
my machine or I'm port forwarding into a
data center in Ireland where my cluster
is running it just it just works which
was really really cool to me at least
so how do we create a pod I have a bit
of code here so I have this simple
stupid application the application
so I didn't want to show you any code
because I thought that was too
complicated for you so I it's kind of
wondering everything else works did I
screw something up this is when I wish I
could tap dance or sing or something to
entertain you while he was fixing it but
trust me you don't want to hear me sing
something ah there it is yes what did I
do something wrong it's fine don't worry
about it that is that is a VTech code
for yes you idiot you did but I fixed it
okay there is an app in here the app is
just a pure a spirit that core
application it doesn't what it does it's
not important the code is here and you
can download that code if you want to
have a look at it it's on github I think
otherwise I'll put it there so I have
this thing and if you want to run a pod
you can either do that which I guess
it's a bit small for you to raid in the
bank you could go and do this cube CTL
run generator run - pod slash v1 web app
image blah blah blah and if you do that
it will start a pod for you without you
having to create a Yama file I have done
this command exactly once in my entire
career and that is because I want to see
if it worked after that we don't do that
anymore
because what we want to do is we want to
create these files instead so this is a
Yama file that defines a pod so it
defines what I want to run inside of my
pod and it starts out with saying what
API version am I using me one there are
a bunch of different ones depending on
the resource type you're creating you
need to figure out what API version
you're in whatever what you do is you go
to Google and you go kubernetes pod
Yambol example and then you take that
and you copy it and then you modify to
what you need that's what I do at least
it works perfectly fine unless you can
remember all the different versions in
your head you tell it what kind it is
it's a pod
and you give you some metadata in this
case I'm giving it the name web app so
that's the way that if I want to go and
look at it I can go cube CTL get and
then web app and it will give me my or
get pulled web app I have some labels
I'll get back to labels later on ignore
it
there's a spec in here so this
specification tells the system for this
pod what is it that I really want to
want to run and in this case I'm telling
it I want to run one container it's
going to be cold
web app name of the container doesn't
really matter that much I give it a so
this is the docker image I want to run
right now I'm hosting it in my sure come
Redis or a docker container registry or
image registry and I tell its image pool
policy is just when you pull this
because urine I'm not gonna be
responsible for doing the pulling so I'm
not going to go docker pool instead the
kubernetes is going to do it for us or
the cubelet is going to tell kubernetes
to do it I want to tell it to make sure
that that happens at a reasonable time
so always is good because you don't end
up with if you do things like pushing
the same image with the same name and
the same tags for example then always
we'll sort that out I might have done
that once or twice so doing it always
kind of solves you from that problem but
you can also tell it to only pool if
it's not available and so on so it can
be a bit optimized then you tell it what
ports you want to bind so I want to have
port 80 on my container so basically
give me a port 80 bound to my pod
resources I'm gonna tell it that just as
I can with docker that you don't get to
use more than I need 64 Meg's of memory
and I need a quarter of the core this
CPU thing depends on where you're
deploying it if you're deploying in an
local hardware with an Intel processor
this I think means a quarter of an a
hyper thread but if you pull it push it
to a sure it becomes a quarter of a
virtual core so it kind of depends on
where you end up but it's a resource
limitation saying I need at least a
quarter of a core and for memory I'm
also saying that I'm not allowed to use
more than hundred twenty-eight Meg's if
you go about 128 Meg's you're doing
something wrong kill the container and
restart it for me
and the same thing for CPU if you use
more than half a cord on
it's actually going to go above this in
some cases and it would probably want to
get killed but I'm trying to limit the
CPS as well one thing to note here if
you start doing this locally and you
have a little micro-services
architecture that you want to run on
your machine and you give every little
service a quarter of the core very very
fast you realize that you don't have a
lot of course on your machine and it
stops deploying stuff for you so these
limits are great to have in production
when you're running on your local
machine this will kind of kill you once
you get into up to a few pods on your
machine and finally since there's
security involved I need to tell
kubernetes how to pull my image I've
told it that the image is available at
Kate's for devs dahshur CR dot io but
that is a private repo so I need to give
it credentials and normally you would do
docker login rights but once again we
are not pulling it courtesies so the way
that we tell kubernetes to pull an image
that is in the private repo is that we
give it we put a secret which is a
username and a password inside of the
cluster and then we tell the cluster
that you can find the username and
password in a secret cold case for devs
and then that is inside of your cluster
so that whenever I push a pod or apply a
pod it will go and use those credentials
for my access so having that up we can
go out here I'm in that same folder who
will do a cube CTL apply - eff like that
open this up so remember what to do it's
up and running we do cube CTL gets pods
you can see that there is a one pod up
here there's one out of one ready
because I'd only put up one pot it is
running it has zero restarts and it was
8 seconds since I started it when I did
the get command then we can say cube CTL
port - for 4 forward web app 8080 port
80 like that it looks up here and if I
pull up my browser we go localhost port
not that port 8080 that is my
application up and running if I go out
here and I killed my port forwarding I
try to refresh this it doesn't respond
so I'm not faking this I was actually
talking to my pod and also kind of
interesting or not interesting but
interest semi interesting is that is my
pod running in docker so once again
kubernetes is not something that is
separate from anything else is it just
automates creation of things in my code
docker container runtime which means
that since this docker container runtime
is running on my machine I can see all
the pods that are up and running or all
the containers in different pods running
on my machine at the moment we'll do
cube CTL delete hold
web app and
now it's gone nope that would have been
cool if that worked there it is now it's
gone there is a graceful shutdown period
for docker images or docker containers
so a nice turret that core application
does take a few seconds through to
basically die that is running a pod
that's as simple as lit that's it takes
a few seconds to get started with with
runaway kubernetes on your machine
installed aquifer desktop take that
little box and you're up and running
with doing at least pods to begin with
however you should never create pods
like that like I just did so why did I
show you I don't know it's up felt like
a good place to start and it's the thing
you do you often pull up a pod just to
see that stuff works but we shouldn't
use pods manually because if you do if
you want to do a load balanced
environment then you're kind of screwed
because now if you want to have two pods
two instances running you will have to
do under view cube cube CTL apply you're
gonna have two different yeah Mel files
because they do need to have different
names because otherwise it's just gonna
be considered an update to the previous
one so you need one Yama file for each
instance of your pod that you want to
run and then you have to cross your
fingers that they are put on two
different worker nodes because if you
put if you decide that you want to have
three replicas having three replicas on
one node is just dumb so you want to use
something called a replica set no the
picture has nothing to do with the topic
but it was a cute picture but before we
can get started repping assets is
basically a way for me to deploy
something to my Kumaresh cluster and say
I want to have a set of replicas and I
want to have four instances running for
example and if you don't find four
instances then please spin up enough to
see that there are four instances but if
there are more than four instances
please go and kill the ones that
shouldn't be there however before we get
started there's one thing we can need to
figure out because just getting started
with replicas sets without thinking it's
bad it's gonna end up with that we need
to understand labels I mentioned when
you saw my pod that there in my pod
llaman there was a little labels thing
that I said you should ignore labels are
really cool because
anything in kubernetes any resource that
you create in kubernetes can have a
label or multiple labels labels are
literally key value pairs in strings so
it's a key and a value they're both
strings you can add them to your
metadata for your resource and then you
can use that to find different things if
you have 600 pods running in your
cluster you can go and say please get
all the pods where the label x equals y
okay why is this important because
that's the way the replica sets work
replica sets don't own any pods at all
so when you create a replica set they
don't own any pods when they create a
new pod they don't own it so it may
instead what they do is they have a
label selector that basically says I
want to have at least X amount of pods
running in my cluster with the
corresponding set of labels that allows
us to do be very very flexible because I
don't tell you how you need to organize
your pods and the labels and how to find
them and everything it's up to you you
can do whatever scheme you want it's
really really flexible and very simple
it also means that if you set up a pod
on your own with basically just sort a
pod for me and you happen to have the
same label set that that your replica
set requires if you add a replica set
after the fact that you created your pod
first your replica set will adopt that
pod because it just happens to have the
same label set it doesn't really care
whether or not it is the same pod it
will just adopt that thing and if it
doesn't find and enough pods with that
label set that you've told it or that
label selector it will go and create new
pods based on the specification that
you've told it basically a template
saying here is my pod template if you
don't find enough pods this is the
template you should use so if you look
at that it looks like it looks like this
know the role it looks like
replicas said there it is it looks like
this so a replica set is inverse API
version app / v1 it's called a replica
set when you're doing cube CTL or cube
control you can call it RS instead of
replica set because replica set is
really long you give it a name you give
it a label this label here is just
information about my replica set has
nothing to do with other labels I was
talking about this is just a way for me
to find replica sets based on labels if
I wanted to do and here is my
specification for my replica sets I want
to run three instances of my pod and the
selector is this match labels I want to
have three pods in my applicator in my
cluster running that has the label app
set to web if you don't find three
replicas with that here is a pod
template this part here from row 13 and
down is an exact copy of the podium all
I just showed you for for the pod is
just you put one level on top of it and
obviously the label set for your
template has to correspond to your label
selector because if it didn't it would
mean that hey I can't find enough pods
schedule a new pod hey I can't find
enough pods schedule a new pod hey I
can't find a pod schedule it's gonna
suck and also there is built-in security
for that so if you try I did the other
day and by mistake it actually tells you
that they don't correspond so it's not
gonna work so it's gonna fail when you
try to but if I take this here we go
back out here we go to my replica sets
we do cube CTL apply - eff that that
goes up we do a cube CTL get all so get
all will give you all resources which is
not true at all it will give you all of
your pods and your services and your
replica sets and a few other things but
it won't actually give you all resources
there's a limited set that you get back
but this is the important interesting
part that I want to say replica set
desire the three
turn three ready three age four seconds
so I know that they're all up and
running and I can see there are three
pods up here running the cool thing here
is that if we do this we do that and we
start another one of these we put that
on the side there that we do CLS there
we can go and do that was not what I
wanted cube CTL get towards - - I
thought I want to show you something I
did there it is
- - watch this is going to show me pods
but it's also going to stay here so you
see it locks up the terminal what it
does it watches for changes if I go back
out here and we say cubes CTL get pods
I could spell I'm so Sweden I can't
spell cube see cube CTL deletes pod and
we want the pod let's take that pod you
are gonna die my friend there it is as I
killed that pod you can see on this side
here my pod went into terminating States
once that goes into terminating States
all of a sudden there's a new one that
basically spins up straight away so that
goes into terminating that goes it
depending then creating terminating
terminating terminating running and now
if I go and look at the end result of
that
I really cannot get this right yes I
know said alias K which is awesome
because you don't have to write cubes
here but I wanted everybody to see that
I'm typing cubed CTL all the time and
not K but there in the end this is what
we are noting as you can see the t44 FM
has been transformed into another poll
so whenever I kill a pod and not the pod
gets added if I were to manually create
another pod it would kill that pod for
me and the replica set basically keeps
everything in check for me and if you
ever want to remove a pod from a replica
set for example you have a misbehaving
pod that you don't want to kill you want
to debug it you just go in and you
update that pod and rename change the
label select save label set for it so
that it doesn't fit into the replica set
anymore then all of a sudden your
replica set is going to spin up a new
pod to replace the one that just died or
disappeared and you can keep on
debugging your pod that was misbehaving
for example but now we have a problem
because now we have multiple pods and we
want to be able to load balanced them
but we cannot talk to them right now
because now we have multiple pods that
are coming and going so I don't have an
end point to communicate with and that's
why we need something called services so
a service in a kubernetes it's a really
weird thing it doesn't actually create
anything it's a resource you create in
your cluster that says I want to have a
unique end point in my cluster that I
can call and it will then use that to
figure out what pods I should be
targeting and load balance across the
pods that matches the services once
again label selector so late a service
is basically a fixed point where I can
reach a set of pods based on their label
selector and the cool thing here is that
the label selector doesn't need to
target a specific type of pod you could
have multiple different types of pod
with the same labels and your service
will basically randomly send you two
different types of pods which is awesome
and also really really scary and hard to
do something useful with but it would be
kind of useful
some cases I think so what is a service
well let me go out here I'm gonna show
you services are cool I did leave my
replica set up and running so I still
have a bunch of pods in here but I can't
talk to him unless I choose a specific
pod so what I've got here is I've got a
service this is my service here very
simple the app version v1 it's a service
it has a name it has a spec so it's a
cluster I piece the service there are a
couple of different types of services
this is a cluster IP one which gives you
a virtual IP address inside of the
cluster and whenever you call that
virtual IP you end up at this service
here and that then causes you to proxy
through the cube proxy and a few
networking thing is that I don't we
don't need to get into but basically it
gets a virtual IP address that we can
use it uses a lecture in this case I'm
selecting all of the pods that I
currently have running because they all
have the the label apps at the web and
I'm saying that hey I want you to listen
for TCP connections I want you to listen
for port on port 80 and I want to
forward it to port 80 on the pods that I
am selected take that go back out here
do that cube CTL get all you'll see here
now that I have another service there's
always a service in your cluster called
kubernetes and the name of your service
is also a DNS entry so you can just go
inside of your cluster you could just go
and do an HTTP call or rest call - HTTP
colon slash slash kubernetes and that
would end up at the kubernetes api is on
the control plane but i got one called
web here it's got a cluster IP which is
10 108 46 150 I don't really care but we
can say cube CTL port - forward service
web app was it called web app which
called web only 8080 port 80 yes slash
in there there is if I go back out here
press refresh I'm now talking to my
service which is awesomely and enough
load balancing not at all that is
because it's actually not talking to the
service it's the way that port forward
works in capital is that it chooses the
first IP address in the matched
pods and port forwards to that specific
pod so it doesn't go through the service
because that has to go through the cube
proxy in a few things so it just selects
one pod but you can use it to basically
say I want to talk to one of the pods in
this this thing here and internally in
your cluster talking to that endpoint
would cause you to talk to a random set
of your pods just gonna go and it's just
gonna go and delete that I don't need
that anymore and we'll do cube CTL
delete RS Web App
and now my cluster should be empty yep
all gone
so services are chemical they are
essential for you to communicate with
your pods you can never talk pod to pod
because they might come and go services
will give you a six point six place also
you cannot actually really find your
pods pods don't get specific IP
addresses they get random IP addresses
so there's no way for you to really
initiate pod - pod communication in a
very simple way they are a little bit
more complicated though and that's the
fact that you can go and create
different types of services you can have
something called a node service for
example that will bind a port on each
one of your nodes in your cluster and
then forward that port to the set of
pods for example that allows you to
basically have an entry point entry
application through any of your nodes
which you can then load balanced with a
load balancer in front of it for example
to blow mats across your nose and so on
there are a couple of different ones and
they're a bit more complicated but
you've got the general gist of a service
is a dns name that you can use inside of
your cluster to communicate with a set
of pods you've also got something called
ingress controllers ingress controllers
are basically services on steroids they
have the same idea of marshaling
requests to different pods but they also
have much smarter logic saying that
they're http-based so they can say if
you go to slash X you should go to this
service if you go to slash why you
should go to this service if you go with
this header you should end up on this
service so it's basically a way for you
to come into your cluster and based on
your HTTP call get redirected to a bunch
of different services inside of your
cluster which then redirects to the
individual pods so you can have this one
entry point in that fans out across your
whole micro-services architecture
internally there are a bunch of them
available the simplest one is nginx
which is based on nginx you guessed it
but there's also things like Ambassador
or traffic sto with different levels of
features I have worked a little bit with
Ambassador at Norfolk
which is nice because you you add
annotations to your pods and then
magically they get wired up into your
ingress controller so whenever you
deploy a new service you can add and say
hey I want this thing to actually answer
on this address here and then your pod
automatically gets traffic through
ambassador for an easy easy deployment
whereas nginx requires a bit of
configuration and sto is a whole
different topic because it also rewrites
your entire service stack into being a
network or a service mesh instead with
much more control so it's a higher level
thing than than just ambassador and
nginx we also got deployments so
deployments is the last sort of resource
level so we've got pods right and on top
of pods we put replicas sets so replica
sets generates pods we don't create pods
because we don't get load balance and it
will be the whole taking care of
multiple replicas so we have replica
sets but we have one thing on top of it
called the deployment so a deployment
creates a replica set and the replica
set create pods the reason for this is
deployment if you define the deployment
it will create these things for you but
if you ever updates every deployment you
can tell that hey I want to update this
whole deployment here and please do that
in the way that you take down one pod at
the time in different nodes over time
make sure that they are up and running
for at least 20 seconds before you pull
down the next one or take it to at the
time but leave or always leave these
many pods running with the previous
version so it's basically a nice rolling
update throughout your cluster that you
can roll back if you want to so it gives
you one one higher level of control and
this going to quickly show you that in
here I have a last level here it's my
deployment so deployment is kind
deployment it has the replicas thing
right in here so it basically has the
setting for your replica sets inside of
the spec and then so this is your your
replica spec and then inside of your
replicas
you have a template and this is the
template for the containers that you
want to run for that replica sets it
basically merges this Yama file merges
your pods back with your replica sets
back with the whole deployment spec on
top of it in this case I also want to
deploy a few other things so these
things here three dashes in a Yama file
basically means this is a new resource
so we can have multiple resources in one
file then I'm also going to play deploy
one individual pod in this case and the
individual pod is going to be ready
spawn so you don't want to have Redis in
multiple pods because it's gonna be less
effective cache if we put it like that
so we want one of these so I'm going to
deploy one of those I'm just gonna use
the the image Redis from docker hub then
I'm going to deploy a service in here
which is a cluster IP service that's
called Redis so if you go into the DNS
asking for Redis it's going to point
towards the the apps called Redis port
TCP port 363 Nats 79 basically it's a
service in front of your your radius
cache and then I'm going to put up a
service here but this time I'm going to
use an Oda port node ports will as I
said previously quickly they will map at
random you can select it but just just
say a random port on each one of your
nodes so basically all knows get the
same random port or each each node yeah
and that node that port on your node
which is going to be like 32 thousand
four hundred and sixty two completely
random stupid port in a specific
specified rock port range that will
automatically get forwarded to port 80
on this service which is then forwarded
to port 80 on your your actual node so
if I create this deployment
like that you'll see cube CTL good Oh
you will see that I have now a
deployment a replica set three replicas
a Redis cache a Redis service and a node
port called web and the node port here
says hey I'm listening two ports three
two four six nine that means that port
three four two three two four six nine
on any one of your worker nodes will go
to that service and then port forward to
your your notes or your pods sorry in
the case of docker for desktop it
actually Maps your localhost on that
port so if I go localhost in that port
I'm now talking straight into my mic
pods so I can go in here and have a look
at my application and we can see that it
can communicate with Redis because you
can see the ready stuff so that's kind
of cool and that allows us to basically
put a load balancer in front of all of
our worker nodes and then have the load
balancer load balanced across the worker
nodes on that port and then internally
that port will map to a service which is
then load balanced across to the
different pods inside of your cluster so
that's kind of one way to get into your
placate your cluster from the outside
then I'm just gonna go and say justice
you can do apply F and give it a file
with all of your things that you want to
apply you can do delete F and it deletes
everything defined in that file which is
nice my cluster is now all clean
so deployments nice way for you to
handle rolling updates and managing
things like that in a nice and easy way
and all of these llamó files can nicely
be put into source control version
manage and everything like they should
so you always know what's running in
your cluster if you want to redeploy
something you just run that ya know file
again so what else do we need well we
need some configuration we need to be
able to configure our pods to do what
they should be doing
we need to be able to add storage and we
need to be able to do some health
monitoring these are kind of the main
things that we need to sort out besides
being able to run our containers
configuration is fairly simple if you
have worked with docker before you know
that in doctor we get configuration into
our docker containers either by doing
environment variables or we do volume
mounts right so we mount files into our
application and we read those files
suite if we change the logo up in the
set corner we're done because we do
exactly the same thing in kubernetes the
main difference is where we store the
values we put into our environment
variables and into our files that we map
in there so here's an example of
something called the config map a config
map is a resource in kubernetes that
contains configuration and then you can
map information from a config map into
your pods using a volume mount or an
environment variable so here we have the
config map my config map that has the
data timeout which is a string that
corresponds to five minutes and then in
my pod I define that hey I want to have
an environment variable call timeout I
want to get the value from a config map
key reference the name of my config map
is my config map and the key is my tease
timeout and then once you start this pod
it will go and look for that config map
find the value and inject that as a
environment variable and you can also go
and do the same thing with files so you
can have a config map with the contents
of a file and then you can take that
content and mount it into your pod and
say whatever it's in this this config
map under the value config dot Jason
please map that into in this case slash
app slash configure Jason in my
application this can I see you got your
config together with your application
where it should be
little short demo of how that works is
we look at our config map here I have a
this is just my well actually let's
start here I have my config map it has a
statement which is just a string camera
it's also
and I have an app settings Jason that
sets a value like this and then I have a
web pod here and as you can see it does
a few things it has the environment
variable name like that set to a
reference to the web config config map
and the key statement so that
environment variable will be set to that
value and down here I'm creating a
volume called config volume based on the
config map web config web config and
then I go and say I wouldn't mount the
app settings to adjacent thing into app
setting start production that JSON in my
application which means that anything in
that upsetting situation is going to
override the one that is in my
application if I've got these two I can
go out here config will do cube CTL and
here the important part is that we
deploy we deploy that one first because
that has to be there otherwise you can't
map in the map an environment variable
once that is deployed I can go and
deploy my web and then we can say cube
CTL Port knows f8 last one
nope it was supposed to be pulled web or
just web like that and if I go back out
here and i refresh this on port 8080 we
can go to configuration and it can just
verify that it does say kubernetes is
awesome
and it did get configuration from
kubernetes config map in here as well so
it did read everything properly so once
again we store our config together with
everything in the cluster I'm just gonna
kill this delete - f actually we can do
delete
come on and finally no we'll just leave
that
so config Mac config like that it's
quite nice you put your config in there
and then when you're running in your
cluster or your local cluster your pods
will just read from that specific
cluster which is quite nice we've also
got something called secrets and I just
want to mention secrets because they are
the same thing as config maps but they
are secret so the values inside of a
secrets instead of a config map is base
64 encoded that is very secret it has
nothing to do with being safe as in
secret that but you can set access
rights to to a secret for example but
the whole idea of doing the
base64-encoded is more of an intent
basically saying stuff in secret should
be credentials and things like that
stuff in config maps should not and then
it's more of a sort of intent kind of
thing with the name it's it's not
actually safe in any way whatsoever I
would suggest getting some other way of
storing credentials like for example a
keyboard in a shoe or something like
that you've also got something called
image pull secrets I mentioned that when
in my all of my podium files it says
image pull secrets basically saying what
credentials should I use when I pull my
images and you create a this is nice
right that's easy to read you create a
pull secret by telling cube CTL that I
want to create a secret it's a docker
registry secret you give it a name you
tell it what server to use username
password and the email you can put in
whatever you want because it doesn't
matter and then those credentials are
being reused whenever you try to pull an
image which can be a useful thing
storage and storage is basically docker
volumes with some extensions so I'm not
going to show you but you map in volumes
and depending on your provider you can
use different types of volumes there are
a few different types but for example if
you're running in Asher you can take an
azure disk or an usher file and you can
map that as storage inside of your pod
in AWS you can I have AWS
elastic block store for example so it
gives you storage external to your
cluster that is persistent you don't
want to store things in your pods
because they'll come and go so external
storage is quite important and the final
thing is that I mentioned was container
health monitoring and the way that we
monitor health in kubernetes is
something called the aliveness probe so
liveness probe is in its basic form you
can set it up to be an HDPE call to a
specific endpoint in your application
and if that endpoint returns HTTP 200 to
399 all those status codes are
considered I'm up and running and
everything is fine other than that if
it's not any of those status codes it's
considered something is wrong and then
in your definition of aliveness probe
once again
HP get is the simplest thing you can do
much more complex probes but it's the
idea is that every X seconds in this
case every three seconds it will do a
probe and whenever in this case it fails
to probe three times in a row the
container is considered failed and will
get restarted and you can also tell it
that I want to delay it three seconds
don't start probing until after a few
seconds because there's a bit of a
startup time for my pod for example I'm
actually not going to show you because I
want to show you something a bit more
and I'm a bit late the lightness probe
is kind of that all that you're gonna
see it's basically if you turn it off it
tails but I want to mention readiness
probes as well so readiness probes are a
bit complicated compared to lifeless
probes because when a lifeless probe
fails three times in my case for how
many times you have decided it should
fail it will restart the container
that's very good if your container is
misbehaving or failing in some way but
not failing in such a way that your
container restarts readiness probes is
it works in the same way and you define
it in the same way but instead of
liveness probes you write readiness
probe all the other configuration is the
same the difference is that if your
readiness probe fails you're not
restarted but you're being removed from
a service rotation so basically any
service that is fronting your pod will
use your pod so basically no calls will
be made to your pod it will be taken out
of load-balancing rotation and then
whenever you're ready nest probe starts
responding is proper codes again to
hundreds for example it will go and plug
it back in and it will get part of the
rotation that is kind of neat because it
means that if you get an overloaded pod
your pod can go and say I have too much
to do don't send me more anymore request
to me but I don't want to get restarted
because I'm working or if you have like
a very long running task and you can
only do one at a time you might have
many many pods in there and they can
basically take one request at a time and
every time they get a request in they go
and say I'm not ready they get taken or
out of the load-balancing and they can
do their work and then they come come
back in again
so the redness probe is logically the
same kind of requests or check but
instead of restarting it just removes it
from getting more requests other than
that I would suggest that you go and
play with it there I must honestly say
I've been coding for 28 years now and
lately it's hard to make me think coding
is really fun 2 degree where I want to
sit at home and play with my computer on
weekends I have other stuff to do but
this was actually kind of cool it got
getting started with this it's just so
simple because you can try all of these
little things and every little thing you
want to try I want to try to put up a
pod with in service in front of it takes
you 5 minutes to do you can do little 5
minutes here and 10 minutes there and
then slowly you start trying all these
things and it's really quick and once
you're done you're just go and delete
whatever is in your cluster and it's all
gone so you don't have this thing of are
there's so much work to get started or
I'm going to leave my machine in a weird
state it's just spin up a cluster run
some stuff in it kill whatever it's in
there and then go and have dinner thank
you all for listening
[Applause]